Adelantemos una década a 2012,
yo ingresaba en mi tercera escuela de bajo rendimiento como directora.
Iba a ser la cuarta directora de Strawberry Mansion en cuatro años.
Fue etiquetada como:
"De bajo rendimiento y persistentemente peligrosa"
debido a sus bajos puntajes en los exámenes
y al alto número de armas,
drogas, asaltos y detenciones.
Poco después de acercarme a la puerta de mi nueva escuela
y tratar de entrar,
encontré la puerta cerrada con cadenas,
Podía oír la voz de Ashley en mis oídos
diciendo, "¡Señorita! ¡Señorita!
Esto no es una escuela".
Los pasillos eran opacos y oscuros por una mala iluminación.
Había un montón de pilas de muebles viejos dañados
y pupitres en las aulas,
y había miles de materiales y recursos sin usar.
Eso no era una escuela.
A medida que avanzaba el año,
me di cuenta de que las aulas estaban casi vacías.
Los estudiantes estaban asustados:
asustados de sentarse en filas con temor de que algo sucediera;
miedo porque eran objeto de burlas en la cafetería por comer comida gratis.
Tenían miedo de todas las peleas y todo el acoso.
Esto no era una escuela.
Y ahí estaban los maestros,
increíblemente temerosos de su propia seguridad,
así que tenían bajas expectativas de los estudiantes y de ellos mismos,
y eran totalmente conscientes de su papel
en la destrucción de la cultura de la escuela.
Este fue lo más preocupante de todo.
Ya ven, Ashley estaba en lo cierto,
y no solo sobre su escuela.
Para demasiadas escuelas,
para los niños que viven en la pobreza,
sus escuelas realmente no son escuelas en absoluto.
Pero esto puede cambiar.
Déjenme contarles qué se está haciendo en la secundaria Strawberry Mansion.
Cualquiera que haya trabajado conmigo les dirá
que soy conocida por mis lemas.
(Risas)
Así que hoy, voy a utilizar tres
que han sido de suma importancia en nuestra búsqueda del cambio.
Mi primer lema es:
si vas a liderar, lidera.
Siempre he creído
que lo que sucede y lo que no sucede en una escuela
depende del director.
Yo soy la directora,
y tener ese título me obliga a liderar.
No iba a permanecer en mi oficina,
no iba a delegar mi trabajo
y yo no iba a tener miedo de hacer frente a cualquier cosa
que no fuera buena para los niños,
me gustara o no.
Yo soy una líder,
así que sé que no puedo hacer nada sola.
Así, reuní un equipo de liderazgo de primera categoría
que creía en las posibilidades de todos los niños,
y juntos, abordamos las cosas pequeñas,
como restablecer todas las combinaciones de los casilleros manualmente
para que cada estudiante pudiera tener un casillero seguro.
Decoramos cada tablón de anuncios en ese edificio
con mensajes brillantes, coloridos y positivos.
Retiramos las cadenas de la puerta principal de la escuela.
Reemplazamos las bombillas dañadas,
y limpiamos todas las aulas a fondo,
reciclando cada, cada libro de texto que no fuera necesario,
y desechamos miles de materiales y muebles antiguos.
Usamos dos contenedores de basura por día.
Y, por supuesto, por supuesto,
abordamos las cosas grandes,
como reconvertir todo el presupuesto de la escuela
para poder reasignar fondos para tener más profesores y personal de apoyo.
Reconstruimos todo el programa diario de la escuela a partir de cero
para agregar una variedad de tiempos de inicio y fin,
remediales, cursos de honores,
actividades extracurriculares, y asesoramiento,
todo durante el día escolar.
Todo durante la jornada escolar.
Creamos un plan de despliegue
que especificaba dónde encontrar a cada persona de apoyo y oficial de policía
cada minuto del día,
y monitorizábamos cada segundo del día,
y, nuestra mejor invención,
ideamos un programa de disciplina escolar
titulado "No negociables".
Era un sistema de comportamiento
--diseñado para promover siempre un comportamiento positivo--.
¿Los resultados?
Strawberry Mansion fue retirada de la lista de persistentemente peligrosas
en nuestro primer año después de estar...
(Aplausos)
Tras estar en la lista de peligrosas por 5 años consecutivos.
Los líderes hacen posible lo imposible.
Esto me lleva a mi segundo lema:
¿Así es? Entonces, ¿qué hacemos?
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Cuando nos fijamos en los datos,
y nos reunimos con el personal,
había muchas excusas
de por qué Strawberry Mansion era
de bajo rendimiento y persistentemente peligrosa.
Dijeron que solo el 68 % de los niños venían a la escuela de forma regular,
100 % vivían en la pobreza,
solo el 1 % de los padres participaban,
muchos de los niños
provenían de padres encarcelados y hogares monoparentales,
El 39 % de los estudiantes tenían necesidades especiales,
y los datos del estado revelaron
que solo el 6 % de los estudiantes eran competentes en álgebra,
y el 10 % en literatura.
Después de decirnos todas las historias
de lo mal que estaban las condiciones y los niños,
los miré,
y dije: "¿Así es? Entonces, ¿qué hacemos?
¿Qué vamos a hacer al respecto?".
(Aplausos)
Eliminar las excusas en cada paso se convirtió en mi principal responsabilidad.
Abordamos cada una de esas excusas
a través de un desarrollo profesional obligatorio,
allanando el camino para un enfoque intenso en la enseñanza y el aprendizaje.
Después de muchas observaciones,
lo que se determinó fue que los maestros sabían qué enseñar,
pero no sabían cómo enseñar
a tantos niños con habilidades tan dispares.
Así que desarrollamos un modelo de desarrollo de la lección para la enseñanza
centrado en grupos pequeños,
que hace posible a todos los estudiantes lograr sus necesidades individuales
en el aula.
¿Los resultados?
Después de un año, los datos del estado revelaron
que nuestros puntajes han crecido un 171 % en álgebra
y un 107 % en literatura.
(Aplausos)
Tenemos un largo camino por recorrer,
un muy largo camino por recorrer,
pero ahora abordamos cada obstáculo con la actitud
"¿Así es? Entonces, ¿qué hacemos?".
Y eso me lleva a mi tercer y último lema.
(Risas)
Si nadie te dijo que te amaba hoy,
recuerda que yo sí, y siempre lo haré.
Mis estudiantes tienen problemas:
problemas sociales, emocionales y económicos
que Uds. nunca podrían imaginar.
Algunos de ellos son sus propios padres,
y algunos están completamente solos.
Si alguien me pregunta mi verdadero secreto
de cómo realmente mantengo progresando a Strawberry Mansion,
tendría que decir que amo a mis estudiantes
y creo en sus posibilidades
incondicionalmente.
Cuando los miro,
solo puedo ver lo que pueden llegar a ser,
y eso es porque yo soy uno de ellos.
Crecí pobre también, en el norte de Filadelfia.
Sé lo que se siente al ir a una escuela que no es una escuela.
Sé lo que se siente preguntarse
si hay alguna vez va a haber alguna manera de salir de la pobreza.
Pero debido a mi increíble madre,
tuve la capacidad de soñar
a pesar de la pobreza que me rodeaba.
Por lo tanto...
(Aplausos)
si voy a animar a mis estudiantes
hacia su sueño y su propósito en la vida,
tengo que llegar a saber quiénes son.
Así que tengo que pasar tiempo con ellos,
así que me las arreglo para ir al comedor todos los días.
(Risas)
Y ya que estoy allí,
hablo con ellos acerca de cosas muy personales,
y cuando es su cumpleaños,
canto el "Feliz cumpleaños"
a pesar de que no canto nada bien.
(Risas)
A menudo les pregunto,
"¿Por qué quieres que cante si no sé cantar nada bien?".
(Risas)
Y ellos responden diciendo,
"Porque nos gusta sentirnos especiales".
Llevamos a cabo reuniones mensuales en la sala de juntas
para escuchar sus preocupaciones,
para averiguar lo que está en sus mentes.
Ellos nos hacen preguntas como: "¿Por qué tenemos que seguir las reglas?".
"¿Por qué hay tantas consecuencias?".
"¿Por qué no podemos simplemente hacer lo que queramos?".
(Risas)
Ellos preguntan y yo respondo cada pregunta con honestidad,
y este intercambio en la escucha ayuda a aclarar cualquier malentendido.
Cada momento es un momento de aprendizaje.
Mi recompensa,
mi recompensa
por ser no negociable en mis reglas y consecuencias
es haberme ganado su respeto.
Insisto en que,
y debido a esto, podemos lograr cosas juntos.
Ellos tienen claras mis expectativas para ellos,
y repito esas expectativas todos los días por los altoparlantes.
Les recuerdo...
(Risas)
les recuerdo esos valores fundamentales
de foco, tradición, excelencia,
integridad y perseverancia,
y les recuerdo todos los días
cómo la educación puede cambiar verdaderamente la vida.
Y termino cada anuncio igual:
"Si nadie te dijo que te amaba hoy,
recuerda que yo sí,
y siempre lo haré".
Las palabras de Ashley
de "Señorita, señorita,
esto no es una escuela",
están grabadas en mi mente para siempre.
Si realmente vamos a hacer progresos reales
para hacer frente a la pobreza,
entonces tenemos que asegurarnos
de que cada escuela que atiende a niños en situación de pobreza
sea una verdadera escuela,
una escuela, una escuela...
(Aplausos)
una escuela que proporcione el conocimiento
y el entrenamiento mental para navegar por el mundo que les rodea.
No sé todas las respuestas,
pero lo que sí sé es que aquellos de nosotros que somos privilegiados
y tenemos la responsabilidad de dirigir una escuela
que atiende a niños en situación de pobreza,
debemos verdaderamente liderar,
y cuando nos enfrentamos a desafíos increíbles,
tenemos que parar y preguntarnos: "¿Así es? Entonces, ¿qué hacemos?
¿Qué vamos a hacer al respecto?".
Y a medida que lideramos,
nunca debemos olvidar
que todos y cada uno de nuestros estudiantes
son solo unos niños,
a menudo asustados por lo que el mundo les dice qué deberían ser,
y no importa lo que el resto del mundo les diga qué deberían ser,
siempre debemos darles esperanza,
toda nuestra atención,
la creencia inquebrantable en su potencial,
expectativas consistentes,
y debemos decirles a menudo,
si nadie les dijo hoy que los amaba,
recuerden que nosotros sí, y siempre lo haremos.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Gracias, Jesús.